YOU CAN WELL UNDERSTAND LOCAL
OFFICIALS’ RELUCTANCE.
IN THE MEANTIME, THAT STIMULUS
THAT WENT UP FOR A PRETTY CLOSE
VOTE IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, A LOT OF FOLKS
SAY DEAD ON ARRIVAL AT THE
SENATE, BUT IT WASN’T ALL
EXCLUSIVE PARTY LINES.
MORE THAN A DOZEN DEMOCRATS WHO
VOTED AGAINST IT INCLUDING
OKLAHOMA DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN AMONG THOSE TO SAY
NO, NO, THIS ISN’T MY CUP OF
TEA, KENDRA HORN.
CONGRESSWOMAN GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
WHY WERE YOU A NO-VOTE ON THAT
CONGRESSWOMAN?
>> GOOD MORNING, GLAD TO BE
HERE.
I WAS A NO VOTE BECAUSE WE’RE IN
MIDST OF A CRISIS WITH COVID-19,
IN ORDER TO GET THE SUPPORT AND
STIMULUS WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY’RE
TIMELY, TARGETED AND
TRANSPARENT.
REQUIRING THAT BILLS BE PASSED
THROUGH THE HOUSE, SENATE AND
SIGNED INTO LAW TO GET THE HELP
TO OUR COMMUNITIES, FIRST
RESPONDERS, BUSINESSES, THIS
DIDN’T HAVE STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT TARGETED.
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON THE
AREAS THAT COVID-19 HAS IMPACTED
AND THIS BILL CONTAINED A LOT OF
EXTRANEOUS PROVISIONS AND
FINALLY, ON TRANSPARENCY, WE GOT
A 1800 PAGE BILL ON TUESDAY.
AND WE’RE ASKED TO VOTE ON IT ON
FRIDAY.
IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO THIS
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS, WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE OPEN DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION ACROSS THE AISLE TO
GET TO SOLUTIONS THAT WORK FOR
EVERYBODY IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THIS JUST DIDN’T MEET THOSE
BARS.
NEIL: NOW, SOME OPPOSITION WAS
EXPECTED, CONGRESSWOMAN, NOT THE
14, INCLUDING YOURSELF OF THE
DEMOCRATS WHO DIDN’T VOTE FOR
THIS.
NOW, SOME WERE SAYING, WELL,
YOU’RE IN A REPUBLICAN AREA,
YOU’VE WON IN A REPUBLICAN AREA
AND YOU’RE FEELING THE PRESSURE,
I BELIEVE THE OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES REPUBLICANS WERE
SIMILARLY AGAINST THIS.
DO YOU FEEL THAT PRESSURE?
DOES IT PUT YOU IN AN ODD
POSITION?
>> IT’S NOT ABOUT PRESSURE TO
ME.
IT’S ABOUT GOOD GOVERNANCE,
MAKING SURE THAT THE PEOPLE IN
MY COMMUNITY AND THE BUSINESSES,
THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS, GET THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED, AND IN ORDER
TO DO THAT, WE’VE GOT TO GET IT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
WE CAN’T BE PLAYING PARTISAN
GAMES, I DON’T CARE WHICH SIDE
OF THE AISLE YOU’RE ON, WITH
THIS PANDEMIC.
THIS IS NOT A TIME FOR
PARTISANSHIP.
IT’S A TIME FOR US TO GET TO
WORK AND GET THE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT TO OUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, OUR CITIES THAT ARE
SUFFERING, OUR BUSINESSES THAT
ARE TRYING TO KEEP OPEN AND OUR
FAMILIES, MANY OF WHOM HAVE LOST
THEIR JOB THROUGH NO-FAULT OF
THEIR OWN.
THIS IS GO GETTING THINGS DONE
AND GETTING IT DONE THE RIGHT
WAY BECAUSE THE HELP IS NEEDED
AND WE SHOULD ALL COME TOGETHER
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, MORE PEOPLE ARE
TALKING, CONGRESSWOMAN, ABOUT
THE WAY THIS WAS VOTED ON,
WHETHER YOU’RE A DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN, BUT BY PROXY,
REMOTELY, AND THAT THIS, YOU
KNOW, IS PROBABLY NOT A GOOD
PATH TO FOLLOW.
A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
TOLD ME THAT.
DOES THAT GIVE YOU PAUSE?
>> WELL, I SUPPORTED THE CHANGE
TO THE RULES THAT ALLOWED PROXY
VOTING OR REMOTE HEARINGS
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO CONDUCT THE FULL
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE AND IF WE
HAVE SOME MEMBERS THAT HAVE
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS,
AND NEED TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY, I THINK THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE, BUT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO BE FULLY IN
SESSION AND FULLY ENGAGED
BECAUSE THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE TOO GREAT RIGHT
NOW, AND WE HAVE OTHER WORK TO
DO.
I’M ON THE ARMED SERVICES
COMMITTEE, WE HAVE TO FINISH THE
DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION BILL.
WE HAVE TO GET APPROPRIATIONS
DONE.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PROGRAMS WE PASS ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING, AS THEY’RE
INTENDED.
SO ALL OF THESE THINGS HAVE TO
HAPPEN AND WHETHER IT’S IN
PERSON AND I’M HERE, I’M HAPPY
TO BE HERE TO DO THE WORK
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITIES NEED IT,
THOSE SAFEGUARDS ARE IN PLACE,
IT’S JUST FOR THE EMERGENCY.
BUT WE CAN’T STOP CONDUCTING ALL
OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
NEIL: CONGRESSWOMAN KENDRA HORN.